how many times have you committed that
card yeah we are about to play a game
legal or illegal and it is evocative of
a film in which people do lots of
illegal things Charlie's been one of
them and some legal things that would be
new so we are about to play this game
legal or illegal
if it sounds reasonable it's probably
not legal if it sells irrational it's
probably yeah all right it is blank to
park an elephant in a metered parking
spot
[Laughter]
specifically in Florida Gators don't
have Alex are you saying I would say
it's a parking meter someone would have
something to say they would not say
nothing to see a guys keep it moving and
you guys in the documentary the elephant
in the living room it's about what now
your friends illegal or legal to wear
your slippers in public after time if it
is illegal
I should be in jail because they've worn
my slippers past 10:00 in every state
what state are we talking Oh New York in
New York let's think about it there's
nothing to think about
I miss it's legal it's it's New York for
[ __ ] sake how many time do it how many
times have you committed that crime
I don't know if I like the same alright
it's it is blank having a donkey sleep
in your bathtub in the state of Arizona
I have a feeling it's legal to be legal
right
oh it's illegal what no no should be do
they just like barge in there like
they're a donkey in your bathtub sir I'm
gonna ask you one more time
is there a donkey in your bathtub I'm
more traumatized bike lady you are
wearing on slippers it is 10:00 p.m. at
night this is a disgrace
it is legal or illegal to drive a tank
on the fully legal I've actually driven
a tank on the freeway all states it's
legal illegal whole state it's all it's
illegal it cannot be you need a special
escort I think you could wear slippers
and drive a tank and you'd be in trouble
foot just lining up with this it is
blank to keep an ice-cream cone in your
back pocket on a Sunday I'm gonna say
it's legal illegal stupid
[Music]